in this lesson we're going to talk about
percentages so percentages is something
they test you on the act and it's a good
thing to know how to approach in an
efficient and effective manner so we're
going to talk about that in this lesson
let's do a couple examples see if you
can pause the video and do these on your
own and we can check the work together
so example number one it says a number
increased by 22 percent is 61. what is
30
of the number
okay so let's take a look at this so
let's see we have a number we don't know
what it is let's just call it x okay or
n okay we'll just call it x though
increase by 22
now here's the thing okay it's
increasing by 22 so 22 is added on to
the original amount so what you want to
think about is this is actually going to
be
122 percent of its original value 22
percent more one represents the original
amount so that's 122 percent and i
converted it into a decimal by moving
that decimal point two places to the
left right so then it says okay a number
increased by 22 is 61. so this equals
61. so let's go ahead and see what the
the number is so we're going to divide
both sides by 1.22
those cancel one another out let's go to
our calculators here we've got 61
divided by 1.22 so that comes out to 50.
okay so our number is 50 right
so then it says what is 30 of the number
okay now here's the thing we're trying
to find out what 30 percent of the
number is whenever you see the word of
of means
times right so this is actually going to
be 50
times
30 percent which equals
15. and you can do that on your
calculator but i just did that in my
head so
here we had a couple of steps we had to
do percentages a couple of times but the
main thing is to know that you know you
want to convert the percentage to a
decimal and you want to think about you
know whether it's 100 percent plus or
100
minus and that can save you a little bit
of work and just make the problem a lot
easier so see if you can do example
number two on your own pause the video
and we'll go through it together i'll
read it here for you
uh two weeks ago you could bench press
150 pounds okay so for all your weight
lifters out there
and then the following week you
increased your bench press by 15
okay and then this week you increased
your bench press by an additional 20
percent
okay so how much can you bench press
this week so see if you can do that
video pause the uh pause the video and
we're going to go through it here so
basically you're starting with a bench
press of 150 pounds right you're
increasing by 15 so that means you're
now bench pressing 115
of what you were previously right 100
represents the original amount plus an
additional 15 percent and then
you're besting that bench press by 20
which means it's going to be 120 percent
more
so we're going to multiply that whole
thing by 120 so let's go ahead and do
that and we can do it in all all in one
step here 150 times 1.15 times 1.20
so that gives you a 207 pound
bench press
and
there you go so there you have it so
basically that's a
key way to work with percentages think
about that 100 plus or that 100 percent
minus and if you approach it that way
it'll make the problem a little bit
quicker and easier to solve i'll see you
in the next lesson